so Donald Trump is using coronavirus to
push a very nationalist agenda and to
fire up the most rabid
ultra-nationalists in his base the
latest example we already talked about
at the top of the show which is Donald
Trump announcing on Twitter that all
immigration to the United States is
suspended from tweeted last night again
just a quick reminder quote in light of
the attack from the invisible enemy as
well as the great need to protect the
jobs of our great American citizens I
will be signing an executive order to
temporarily suspend immigration into the
United States we don't know what
temporary means we don't know the legal
basis we don't even know if this is
legal but what we've known for a long
time is that Donald Trump would be as
ultra nationalist the president as he
could get away with not necessarily
because these are the policies that he
believes in or that he actually thinks
are the best policies for the country
maybe he does maybe he doesn't doesn't
really matter but because from the start
of his campaign
Donald Trump has positioned himself as
the nationalist candidate and it has
worked to bamboozle voters into
supporting him if you go back to the
campaign in 2015 and into 2016
it was China's killing us I know about
how to stop us from getting screwed on
trade deals even though he didn't but it
was very very effective we don't win
anymore no more Mexican rapists are
going to be coming here were suspending
Muslim immigration to the United States
it's all nationalist language and from
day one at his inauguration that
language of America first referencing an
ugly nationalist slogan from the mid
20th century there have been endless
examples during the presidency but today
I want to focus in on what's been done
during coronavirus to push the
nationalist rhetoric and before I do
that just remember hyper nationalism
ultra-nationalism this is a common
element for lack of a better term of
fascism and as we followed throughout
the Trump presidency we have a number of
different elements of fascism that are
noticeable Trump is not a dictator
fascism is a form of far-right
authoritarian ultra-nationalism often
by a dictator it often includes police
states and lots of things that we don't
have in the American Society right now
but that hyper nationalism is part of it
and Donald Trump is very much excelling
there so let's look at our list under
the guise of coronavirus we've seen the
entire premise of the response from
Trump be focused around China is bad and
we are good so we had early on Trump
first saying China's got this under
control once it became clear that they
didn't have it under controlled from
very much reversed and was calling it
the Wuhan virus he was calling it the
Chinese virus and the rest of it you all
know about it this was setting up the
early stages of a nationalistic response
to coronavirus then of course there's
always some truth to these things the
virus did originate in China then it's
we're closing borders were shutting down
we are isolating now that was the right
move every country mostly did it but
what we're talking about is the building
rhetoric of ultra-nationalism during the
coronavirus response then Trump started
with we've got to start producing
everything domestically we can't rely on
China for masks we can't rely on Italy
for ventilators or whatever the case was
that each product was coming from we've
got to bring all our production
domestically and of course that's
partially true now which is that if we
produced all of this stuff all along
we'd probably have somewhat of an easier
time getting more of these items right
now but it's distracting from the real
failure because the real failure is not
we should have gotten this stuff from
American companies instead of foreign
companies all along you can debate that
maybe it's true maybe it's not the real
failure was disbanding the pandemic
response team not strategically
increasing stockpiles of these elements
not distributing these earlier rather
than playing catch-up in late March that
was the real mistake and it would have
avoided the panic so sure you can get
them all along from the United States or
from other countries the issue is not so
much where these items are produced it's
that we weren't stockpiling them and we
were unprepared and late in distributing
them then it became we must open the
country for liberty and
freedom it's a constitutional issue this
is America were meant to be open
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah fomenting the
mass gatherings the protest governor's
putting in place Public Health
guidelines insisting that these crowds
are behaving appropriately of course the
crowds made up almost exclusively of
Trumpets don't tread on me Tea Party
types Alex Jones style conspiracy
theorists all very nationalist groups
Trump very much instigating and and
firing them up and then now we get to
stop all immigration there's this phrase
never let a good crisis go to waste the
phrase has been attributed to Winston
Churchill I believe falsely I don't
think it's a Churchill phrase I've seen
it attributed to Saul Alinsky I'm not
actually sure where it originated but it
very much applies here it's not been put
in place more acutely than during the
Trump administration and specifically
during the coronavirus fiasco and it may
actually propel Trump to reelection if
we're not careful the nationalist
rhetoric which very often confused
people in the sense that they believe
Trump was good on trade when Trump
didn't really know anything about trade
but it got people to say this is the guy
that will bring America back so to speak
it worked during his campaign and we
have to understand that it may well work
for Donald Trump's own re-election
ultra-nationalism under the guise of
coronavirus laughable at its face things
are going so well that we should reopen
but at the same time things are going so
poorly we need to take the unprecedented
step of suspending all immigration to
the United States completely incoherent
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman we have a just
packed program for you today really glad
you're with us have you ever wanted to
learn to play the guitar but you've had
trouble committing to the time and money
required to actually take lessons I have
the perfect solution for you it's called
fender play it's an app developed by the
iconic guitar company fender it lets you
learn to play your favorite songs in
minutes on your schedule with
interactive video lessons that are
very easy to follow you can use it for
guitar bass or ukulele I've been using
fender play to learn the ukulele I've
gotten a lot better than I thought I
would in a couple of months I had tried
teaching myself using some YouTube
videos didn't really get anywhere night
and day difference since I've started
using fender play and they have
personalized learning paths that will
cater to your musical tastes you can use
it on your phone tablet or computer and
you learn at your own pace which is just
awesome one year of membership gives you
access to thousands of lessons for less
than the cost of one traditional
in-person lesson and when you go to
fender dot-com slash Pakman you'll get
to try it totally free for two whole
weeks free two week trial don't lose out
on that without any commitment that's f
en de our comm slash Pakman PA que ma n
fender dot-com slash Pakman